By the way, Mr. Fumi
, what's wrong with you? I thought that a new force might be needed soon.
Well, Mr. Melty must be busy with official duties, so you
should expand your weapons and g as much as possible.
There's no
guarantee that we'll be able to drive them back if our voice actors were killed, because Raphtalia and the others are the only people we can count on.
I was kicked out of Hero-sama's party and became pessimistic about the future.
For the
most part, he was the only one who was able to play an active role
in the waves.I guess he was envied by his other comrades.It was in May.It was said
that he believed only his comrades' words and banished him.
Are you going to accept the false accusation like this?
Just with that courage you can be
strong I can be strong
Oh so give us a voice You can help
us until we can speak our doubts
[music]
Let's be strong together fyra
Naofumi is pretty good at training men and lana's brave companions who knew how to swim.